[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de pas
vraiment hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec vous
mario becker jean marion major oriane
est notre invité cette semaine et
olivier bernex bonjour je vous remercie
d'être avec nous vous êtes député les
républicains d'eure-et-loir
au programme aujourd'hui le marathon de
la réforme des institutions a débuté les
députés examiner cette semaine en
commission le volet constitutionnel de
cette réforme ils ont acté des
changements symbolique le mot race est
supprimée de la constitution la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité ainsi que la lutte contre
les changements climatiques est inscrite
dans le préambule la réforme du travail
parlementaire elle divise profondément
la loisy l'immigration a été adopté par
le sénat un texte durci par la majorité
de droite facilitation des expulsions
limitation du regroupement familial du
délai de dépôt des demandes d'asile ou
encore restriction de l'aide médicale
d'urgence
là les sénateurs dénature la loi
agriculture et alimentation
après son adoption à l'assemblée elle
était débattu cette semaine au sénat ici
les sénateurs veulent plus de
transparence sur la formation des prix
ils ont largement revu à la baisse
l'objectif d'une alimentation plus saine
et on commence cette semaine avec la
réforme constitutionnelle qui entame son
parcours parlementaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réforme arrivera dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale le 10 juillet
prochain mais cette semaine les députés
l'examiner en commission plus de 1300
amendements ont été déposés est les
députés se sont notamment penchés sur
les modifications de l'article 1 de la
constitution qui définit les principes
fondateurs de la république mari la bat
avant même de pouvoir réviser le premier
article de la constitution
les députés avaient 300 amendements à
examiner en préambule l'occasion pour
eux de discuter de sujets diverses comme
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
le statut de la corse ou encore la
notion de race je m'interroge quand même
sur la porte est aussi symbolique de
d'enlèvements ou de ce terme qui
pourrait donner le signal à quelques-uns
malheureusement que en effet la lutte
contre le racisme n'est peut-être plus
aussi importante qu'elle l'était au
contraire je crois que là on marque
notre notre volonté de supprimer
définitivement la notion même qu'il y
aurait plusieurs races et si tous se
sont félicités de voir le mot supprimé
de la constitution il leur faudra encore
attendre pour décider d'un nouveau terme
pour le remplacer les députés ont aussi
acté l'inscription dans la constitution
de la préservation de l'environnement et
de la diversité biologique ainsi que
l'action contre le changement climatique
une mesure annoncée par nicolas hulot la
semaine précédente
cette inscription aura et sa réponse
dans nos questions une portée symbolique
et normative plus importante que la
seule modification de l'article 34
pour l'opposition ce changement ne revêt
aucun intérêt sur le plan juridique
constitutionnel je ne vois absolument
pas l'apport de cet amendement je trouve
qu'on enfonce des portes ouvertes
elle aura cependant la possibilité de le
discuter à nouveau puisque cet
amendement devra être revoté lors de
l'examen du texte dans l'hémicycle à
compter du 10 juillet prochain olivier
marleix qs est ce que ce sont des
changements nécessaires ou symboliques
qui vous parle
j'ai la vie de philippe gosselin pour
l'instant c'était vraiment le concours
lépine sur sur ce premier article
on a perdu un père duquel beaucoup de
temps pour cesser le jeu chacun veut
faire avancer les causes qui lui qu il
pas un serpent de tout ça je tape
l'ordre est un jeu qu'on n'a pas perdu
beaucoup de temps qu'on n'est pas venu
qu'on tarde à revenir au vrai sujet vos
sujets c'est évidemment que vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure le le poids du
parlement dans nos institutions
toutes les réformes constitutionnelles
depuis 1958 qui ont été menées l'ont été
fait dans le même sens dé renforcer les
pouvoirs du parlement c'est la réforme
de jusqu'à 74 qui permet la saisine du
conseil national c'est la réforme de
philippe se gave a inspiré par sega en
95 qui permet la session unique un temps
réservé une sétif parlementaire et puis
surtout la grande réforme de nicolas
sarkozy en 2008 qui ferment donne
beaucoup de pouvoir le droit de 2,2
commission denquête pour pour
l'opposition le contrôle des nominations
par présidente du président de la
république par les commissions enfin
beaucoup de pouvoir et là c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de 5ème
république
on nous propose une réforme
d'affaiblissement du pouvoir du
parlement dont françois de rugy lui
estime que c'est l'occasion justement de
rendre le parlement plus fort encore une
fois oui enfin en tout cas pour
l'instant françois françois de rugy se
rend utile ce que veut le président de
la république un point c'est tout
malheureusement il n'a pas été un grand
défenseur pour l'instant de
l'institution qu'il préside
une fois encore ce sera la première fois
qu'une majorité portera une réforme
d'affaiblissement affaiblissement qu'il
n'y ait pas quelques panneaux tracé
c'est l'encadrement des amendements
qu'on a le droit de déposer qui seront
désormais considérés comme des cavaliers
beaucoup plus souvent c'est le fait que
l'on pourra amendé en commission mais
plus en séance publique
c'est enfin cesser nombreux c'est aussi
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
qui fait qu'à un moment on n'arrive plus
à assurer la permanence sa présence
physique notamment pour des petits
partis minoritaires qui seront qui
seront totalement submergé par le par ce
flot des textes
il est aussi question de revoir
l'organisation des semaines
parlementaire de renforcer la mission de
contrôle du gouvernement de renforcer
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
est-ce que ça ça va pas dans le sens
souhaité un meilleur travail du
parlement à ceci près que même que dans
la semaine de contrôle par exemple dans
la sienne dit sétif parlementaire le
gouvernement pourra profiter le temps et
mettre des des projets de loi
d'initiative gouvernementale ecoterra
donc non on est moi cette réforme je la
vois comme vraiment une avancée de la
technostructure on nous fait croire fort
et rationaliser le parlementarisme comme
comme en 1958 c'est une c'est une aile
c'est une c'est une blague
il n'était pas nécessaire de réformer
cette procédure par le passé c'est quoi
le problème dans notre pays aujourd'hui
90% des textes que nous adoptons ce ne
sont pas des initiatives des
parlementaires son initiative de
l'administration du boulot à peine dire
du gouvernement cela représente le
gouvernement est souvent les ministres
mettent leur nom en bas d'un papier que
l'administration leur à leur a préparé
donc cette logorrhée législatives qu'on
nous représente et qui empoisonnent la
vie des français qui est devenu
totalement illisible c'est le problème
de la technostructure est ce que ce
qu'il faut réformer dans ce pays ce
qu'il faut rationaliser dans ce pays
c'est la technostructure ce texte ait
plus de pouvoir encore pour la
technostructure c'est le projet de
monsieur macron c'est vraiment la
réforme de la technostructure contre les
représentants on le disait un peu plus
de 1300 amendements ont été déposés
c'est le double
de 2008 lors de la révision traditionnel
de nicolas sarkozy à ce que cette
révision constitutionnelle devient
fourre tout oui on verra on va quoi ce
tout ça tout ça terrible je pense que
c'est parce que la vision de la réforme
de l'ancien duc à sarkozy elle reposait
sur un projet qui était qui était
extrêmement claire inquiète
effectivement plus de droits pour les
citoyens avec la qpc possibilités de
recours c'est conditionnelle et plus de
droits pour le pour le parlement là on
est sur une méthode qui est un peu
étrange où il ya un paquet avec un texte
optionnel à projets de l'organique un
projet de loi ordinaire où on a
savamment découper tout ça en tranchée
dantec social lui-même bahia il ya les
bus il ya juste des mesures techniques
que je viens d'évoquer essentiellement
du coup ça ouvre la porte puisque tu
sais que tout ça est un peu ne pas grand
sens voilà porté au concours lépine un
bon puisque richard ferrand a reconnu
cette semaine qu'un accord avec le sénat
et est indispensable pour faire passer
cette réforme est ce que cet accord se
fera c'est là où la droite est
majoritaire un oui basse écoutez je suis
pas sonate heures et que bien comprendre
les méandres du sénat c'est je sais
parfaitement que des répliques
c'est parfois c'est parfois je peux oui
mais enfin le sénat défend aussi dans
une majorité qui est plus large que les
réguler républicain d'ailleurs défi des
forts aussi c'est sa vision du
fonctionnement de nos institutions jeu
qui devait fixer des lignes rouges
on verra s'il ya une fois encore il ya
certains sujets de l'art fonctionnel
d'autres dans le projet de loi d'un
projet de loi organique
l'idée du sénat c'est d'une part
d'affaiblissement du sénat est plutôt
même un renforcement notamment sur
l'adoption des lois organiques alors
justement au sénat cette fois le projet
doazit l'immigration profondément
remanié a été adopté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est la droite sénatoriale a réécrit
profondément ce texte de gérard collomb
avant de procéder à son vote mardi un
durcissement assumer un fabien rey caire
au terme de débats animés
le sénat a durci le projet de loisy
l'immigration en adoptant tout d'abord
le principe d'un débat annuel au
parlement sur la gestion des flux
migratoires
une mesure qui pour le groupe communiste
ne sert qu'à une chose à définir des
quotas et à définir le seuil à partir
duquel sera déclenchée quoi qu'il en
coûte et quelle que soit la situation la
machine à expulser a renvoyé à ignorer
les vies ainsi brisé et ce n'est pas la
seule mesures restrictives adoptées par
la chambre haute qui a réduit à 90 jours
le délai pour déposer une demande
d'asile
même si contre l'avis du gouvernement
les sénateurs ont maintenu à 30 jours le
temps imparti pour formuler un recours
les conditions du regroupement familial
ont quant à elle était durcie et l'aide
médicale d'état
remplacé par une aide médicale d'urgence
limité aux maladies graves
fidèle à la ligne l air la majorité
sénatoriale a voulu renforcer la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale notamment
par des mesures de rétorsion contre les
pays d'origine
peu coopératif au retour de leurs
ressortissants et en raccourcissant le
délai de départ volontaire pour les
personnes obligées de quitter le
territoire français
on ne peut pas accepter l'idée que
finalement on arrive seulement à 5% 7%
des reconductions à la frontière
sinon ça veut dire que no no no no
réglementation leurs règles n'ont pas
beaucoup de sens et n'aboutissent pas
porté à 90 jours par le gouvernement
la durée maximale de rétention
administrative pour les étrangers n'a
pas été modifié par les sénateurs qui
ont en revanche supprimé
l'assouplissement du délit de solidarité
votée par l'assemblée nationale
olivier marleix hxc par la fermeté qu'on
résout une crise migratoire une question
il rate war oui surtout tu ne sais pas
par ce texte si c'est votre votre votre
question donc clairement ce texte c'est
puisque c'est ça le point de départ que
même ceseda parfaite illustration de
l'illusion macro nien c'est à dire qu'on
nous présente un texte en faisant croire
aux français que ça va changer quelque
chose ce texte c'est au mieux un texte
de réforme de l'engorgement des
préfectures quoi voilà c'est là que ça
peut-être un peu d'effet avec des
mesures hyper technocratique mais qui ne
changeront pas grand chose la réalité ce
même les modifications du sénat n'y
changeront pas grand chose bon on va pas
rester sur les modifications du sénat
malheureusement je pense que je sais pas
de doute sur le fait que la majorité
rovia nation à son à son texte en
réalité c'est que en termes de
reconduite à la frontière de notre pays
avec monsieur macron sur l'année 2017
on est à deux fois moins que sur les
dernières années nicolas sarkozy on est
passé de près de quarante mille ha à
moins de 20000 donc il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de volonté
la ligne du président de la république
puisque on a une semaine où la question
migratoire était au devant de scène elle
est totalement illisible et pardon mais
j'ai vraiment le sentiment qu'on a un
président de la république qui n'a pas
de colonne vertébrale sur ce sujet là en
tout cas j'irais le lundi on refuse
d'accueillir les migrants de l'aquarius
jeune âge m'en réjouis mais le mardi on
dit qu'on va accueillir une partie des
migrants du lifeline je passais dans des
bateaux qui avec une importance dans le
choix du clan des républiques peut-être
eu un jour on est d'accord il ne faut
pas venir en aide se courir de façon
humanitaire ces personnes en difficulté
en méditerranée c'est qu'on peut pas le
un jour est d'accord avec les espagnols
qui disent il faut accueillir sur notre
territoire et des centres d'accueil
et puis le lendemain est d'accord avec
les italiens qui disent non c'est dans
les pays d'origine qu'il faut accueillir
tout ça est totalement totalement
incohérent n'y a pas de colonne
vertébrale n'y a pas de ligne le sujet
c'est que on est face à une crise
migratoire sans précédent pourquoi sans
précédent parce qu'en fait c'est une
crise d'abord démographique le continent
africain qu'il faut aujourd'hui un peu
plus d'un milliard d'habitants va dans
les quarante ans qui viennent
doublé de population devra passer de 1 2
milliards après 2,5 milliards on sait
que les flux qui traversent la
méditerranée enfin c'est ça la réalité
qu'il faut que nos élus nos compatriotes
et en tête quand on a découvert les
phénomènes au moment de lampedusa en
2012 y avait environ 500000 personnes
qui commençait à traverser la
méditerranée chaque année aujourd'hui on
estime qu'on est à plus d'un million de
ces épreuves olympiques c'était en 2015
depuis ces flux migratoires ont diminué
non ces flux non non non pas diminuer la
traversée de la méditerranée justement
ces flux continue d'augmenter on est
passé de 500 milles à un flux qui est
aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 2,1 millions
on nous a raconté que c'était des
réfugiés est très très clairement ce
sont des réfugiés de rien du tout j'ai
vu qu'il y avait un bateau qui avait été
arrêté parce qu'ils avaient viré des
gens des diarrhées des migrants avaient
viré d'autres migrants par dessus par
dessus bord qu'est ce qui montre quand
même
l'empathie dont ils sont eux mêmes
capables
et bien que pape a mis ces gens là il y
avait des gens qui venaient du sénégal
expliquez-moi depuis quand de chennai
inde et en russie on s'y prend bien
c'est au niveau européen que cela joue
après neuf heures de discussions dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi l'union
européenne s'est mis d'accord sur un
accord sur cette politique migratoire
est ce que vous vous en féliciter cet
accord est ridicule enfin je sais
vraiment
je passais la soupe concerts dans les
auberges espagnoles comme chacun est
venu avec la phrase qu'il avait besoin
de mettre de montrer à sion d'opinion
des plateformes d'accueil hors des
frontières européennes d'accueil en
europe sur la base du volontariat
cette participation financière y compris
des pays du groupe qu'on appelle devise
grade
ce n'est pas suffisant c'est une vision
c'est une vision commune partagée pas
par l'europe et en europe vous avez
aujourd'hui de ligne vous avez ceux qui
dise stop n'avons plus les capacités
d'accueillir et vous avez ce set exprimé
d'ailleurs assez largement lors dès lors
des élections certain nombre de ces pays
avec des conséquences que l'on a vu le
ministre de l'intérieur allemand a dit
stop on ne peut plus accueillir alors
que l'allemagne est à l'origine en
grande partie celui ci vous pourrez plus
vous avez ceux comme les espagnols qui
disent il faut continuer peut continuer
à cueillir devoir de solidarité et c'est
un nouveau chef de gouvernement verra
combien de temps il tiendra
on a mis tout ça bout à bout ça ne fait
pas une politique européenne ce dont on
a besoin c'est d'une rupture d'une
politique européenne qui fasse qu'enfin
on défende des frontières européennes
cette part dans cette rupture elle n'a
pas été fait pourquoi parce que monsieur
macro n'en a pas voulu
monsieur macron s'est alignée sur la
ligne de ceux qui restent sur une
politique immigrationniste d'ald
accueillent à bras ouverts de tout le
monde même si il fait semblant de se
défendre dans notre pays mais juste pour
finir sur ce texte qu'il y aura une
commission mixte paritaire le 4 juillet
prochain qui est vouée à l'échec si on
voit bien est-ce que du coup la majorité
de droite la droite ne donne pas
finalement le beau rôle au gouvernement
qui pourra jouer la carte de l'humanisme
je vais passer de quelques artisans
envie de jouer ça va encore projet quand
j'écoute monsieur macro moi je je je je
vois en lui le fils spirituel de
françois hollande
il y aura accueilli leonarda en est on
est vraiment peu près ce niveau là
aujourd'hui de vision stratégique sur
notre pays sur la politique migratoire
qui devait celle de la france et
l'europe
alors après la loire asile et
immigration le sénat s'est penché cette
semaine sur la loi agriculture et
alimentation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
assurer un juste équilibre entre
producteurs et distributeurs et une
alimentation saine durable et accessible
à tous voilà l'objectif de ce texte le
sénat examine une loi qu'il a
profondément remanié actant des
différends avec le gouvernement les
sénateurs ont voulu recentrer la loi sur
le revenu des agriculteurs et sur ce
sujet je vous propose d'écouter le
ministre de l'agriculture stéphane
travert lors du début de l'examen du
texte c'était mardi par ce texte
je veux redonner du pouvoir aux
producteurs dans la chaîne de valeur
nous partageons tous le même constat la
situation n'a que trop duré les
agriculteurs subissent de plein fouet
une guerre des prix et ne dégagent pas
ou plus les marges de manoeuvre qui sont
indispensables tente à la rémunération
de leur travail ou de leur capital qu'à
la montée en gamme des productions
alimentaires
cette guerre des prix se nourrit du
déséquilibre de l'offre et de la demande
de l'absence d'organisation de
production de la concentration toujours
plus forte du secteur de la distribution
elle se nourrit parfois aussi de la
défiance des consommateurs et des
injonctions contradictoires qu'ils
envoient aux producteurs et je ne crois
pas que l'on puisse avoir des
productions toujours plus saine toujours
plus élaborés toujours plus durable en
ayant des prix toujours plus bas et des
promotions toujours plus attrayante
olivier marleix qs les sénateurs
communistes et centristes ont imposé
l'utilisation de deux formules claire
lisible dans la construction des prix
agricoles
vous êtes sur un territoire agricole est
une avancée justement pour les
agriculteurs bon je viens vrai sujet sur
la construction des prix et et
l'ambition initiale de ce gouvernement
dans ce sens elle est plutôt dans le bon
sens donner plus de moyens donner plus
de moyens
la profession agricole agriculteurs dans
leurs discussions commerciales ou sont
vraiment aujourd'hui dans une logique du
du fort au faible et donc cette logique
cette logique elle est plutôt bien dans
la réalité c'est effectivement c'est
qu'à l'assemblée
tout ça était très virtuel et on a créé
un
un médiateur des prix milk l'oralité
quasiment quasiment quasiment aucun
pouvoir vous saluer cet ajout du sénat
qu'est ce que je sais comment tout ça
commente us a atterri en réalité moi ce
que je voudrais dire ce qui me paraît un
peu essentiel c'est que on reconnaît qu'
évidemment il ya un problème de de prix
donc on dit on va régler ça pas une
meilleure relation commerciale très bien
évidemment si tu ne sais une très bonne
logique mais la réalité la réalité ce
que en même temps en même temps on
impose une fois de plus des contraintes
totalement asymétrique à nos
agriculteurs
on parle de qualité d'alimentation on
fait comme si en france on mangeait on
avait vocation de manger que des
produits que des produits locaux
d'agriculture françaises alors que en
même temps ces fameux en même temps en
même temps leur offre tout autre chose
on va baisser le budget de la pac
on va besser alité le le revenu des
agriculteurs donc alléchant la france 1
se bat contre la baisse du budget de la
pac c'est un combat perd même passer ces
nouveaux alors parce que jusqu'à présent
la france c'est pas beaucoup c'est pas
beaucoup battu et quand on sait que
michel mises sur la table on n'avait pas
entendu la france dans la france ne
s'est pas battu pour l'instant essayer
de se rattraper mais donc on échange en
fait une hypothétique hausse des prix
bien la grande distribution par une
baisse certaine de revenus et de vrais
sujets une fois encore c'est qu'on
impose on fait on fait comme si c'est
une tartuferie en fait comme si en
france on vivre dans un système fermé
alors que l'europe ne passe son temps à
ouvrir avec des projets d'accords qui
importe qui vise à apporter toujours
plus de produits étrangers ce qui est
une aberration ces contrats de ce qu'on
raconte aux français et qui eux ne sont
soumis à aucune aucune aucune des normes
environnementales qu'on impose aux
français donc il faut sortir de cette
asymétrie
il faut sortir du en même temps qu est
une énorme hypocrisie en la matière il
ya une disposition qui a fait des remous
au sénat c'est l'objectif de 20 % de
produits bio dans les cantines d'ici
2022 retirer en commission finalement
adopté en séance à la quasi unanimité
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
mesure une contrainte supplémentaire
pour les collectivités locales j'ai
plutôt c'est plutôt dense plutôt une
mesure sera un impact sur les prix il
faut pas se faire d'illusions le prix
des repas notamment dans les dents dans
l'est continue c'est plutôt une bonne
mesure sur les produits bio produits ou
produits locaux parce que ça va
permettre d'aider à la structuration
économique de ces deux de ces filières
sur nos territoires qui en ont besoin et
donc c'est plutôt une bonne chose mais
en même temps vous salue et finalement
ce recul du sénat sur les produits
east au sanitaire et c'est un enjeu de
santé publique à la fois pour les
consommateurs pour les agriculteurs eux
mêmes
oui mais une fois encore c'est un enjeu
de santé publique oui mais alors que ce
débat doit être européen il doit être
guidé va être sûrement européen me dois
être dans tous les traités que l'europe
signe avec avec les américains avec les
canadiens avec les pays du mercosur
qu'on arrête d'imposer aux français et
aux français seulement avec une force de
contrôler totalement scandaleuse 1 et
tout est pénalisée aujourd'hui si vous
dépassez un tout petit peu les les doses
autorisées
alors que on est incapable on n'a même
pas la volonté de regarder comme enfin
les autres qu'on invite à venir vendre
chez nous cette incohérence il est
totalement totalement insupportable
c'est fait c'est une aberration je
comprends que les gens n'aient que les
agriculteurs on est en a ras-le-bol et
veuille sortir de ça il n'y a pas
d'espacé suffisant aujourd'hui pour une
agriculture à alternative si on a
intérêt d'ailleurs les falaises les deux
ne s'oppose pas moi j'aime pas le mot je
n'aime pas le mot alternative entre le
conventionnel et serra je pense
qu'effectivement c'est l'intérêt de tout
le monde
évidemment d'emmener agriculture qui
soit de plus en plus raisonner ses
intérêts aussi des agriculteurs de 2,2
de moins dépenser cette mer en cette
matière mais ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
soit on soit cohérent et qu'on ne fasse
pas
et pas n'importe pas pardon des produits
qui ne respectent pas les normes qu'on
impose aux producteurs
allez il est temps à présent de
retrouver un autre partenaire du
figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour olivier ma relaxe on a parlé des
manuels macro et des polémiques qui
s'enchaînent pour le chef de l'état
qu'ils s'agissent de son train de vie ou
des mots qu'il prononce et son image qui
est attaqué est ce que c'est la fin de
l'état de grâce pour pour emmanuel
macron je vis des faits plutôt d'essayer
les journalistes qui redessineront
bardage et dire qu'avec avec humour et
sympathie d'un mais clairement il les a
il les a enchaîné je sais pas d'où ça
vient c'est l'ivresse du pouvoir ou quoi
mais effectivement le lave-vaisselle par
exemple c'est assez je pense à marie
antoinette qui jouent en 1788 à
continuer à aménager le hameau de la
reine
parce que c'est plus grave là au delà de
ces scandaleux même le nom mais pour le
patrimoine national
c'est quand même que en même temps mais
en même temps on va piquer 20 euros à
des retraités qui ont 1280 euros de
retraite ou alors piqué valeurs où
chaque mois parce que les caisses sont
vides et en même temps on commande
500000 euros dressée allant même temps
se construire une piscine à vagues on
songe par écrit mme de absolue mais
voilà la réalité dans le pays si vous
avez des millions de français qui ne
partiront pas en vacances cette année
notamment à cause de la politique de
monsieur mac ronde sur le gasoil sur qui
fait que le pouvoir d'achat on a pris un
coup et là on a entendu beaucoup les
républicains sur ces sujets là vous vous
en parler on a l'impression qu'à défaut
de pouvoir accrocher le président sur le
fond de sa politique eh ben vous du coup
vous l'attaquez celui sur des absents de
style non c'est bien le fond de sa
politique et qui est un jeu quoi c'est à
dire s'il en est là c'est pas sa
politique de fond cdd kfor sais pas je
ne sais pas c'est pas que le coma
richesses les collections nationales
merci à marc antoine est d'avoir fait le
hameau de la reine on a une très heureux
aujourd'hui
ce qui me choque c'est le décalage c'est
le décalage c'est que c'est ce couple ne
se rendent pas compte de l'incongruité
de ski de ce qu'il fait pour lui et en
même temps d'un certain nombre de
mesures je suis aujourd'hui ce qui fait
quand même assez mal au coeur de notre
pays quand je vois le matin à la station
service leclerc d'annette des gens met
15 euros 20 euros d'essence parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de mettre plus mais
pour aller pour aller bosser
c'est scandaleux et qu'on fasse les deux
c'est qu'il ya décalage une déconnexion
qui me paraît totalement totalement
effrayante et c'est bien c'est
effectivement c'est à la fois le style
et le fond de sa politique ont atteint
laurent wauquiez il est resté assez
discret sur tous et toutes ces
polémiques est ce qu'il est mais ce
qu'il est trop en retrait selon vous ces
derniers vous l'avez demandé de prendre
de la hauteur de montrer qu'il était
intelligent et fera donc ses traits
c'est très bien c'est pas rentrer dans
ces pilotes sont au dessus petit sujet
enfin il a parlé des sujets de fond il
on a parlé du gasoil récemment et on a
pris l'initiative aux républicains pour
demander à ce que notamment cette
demande de laurent de cette augmentation
de plus de gasoil les français ne savent
pas c'est pas c'est pas le prix du baril
a il est plutôt bas c'est la fiscalité
écologique décidé par monsieur hulot et
monsieur macro est donc là on est à la
première lame du rasoir il aura la
deuxième lame l'année prochaine on
arrivera à un prix de 1 euro 60 et
quelque deux pour le gasoil donc laurent
wauquiez a dit stop et demandait ce
qu'on annule cette mesure pour l'année
prochaine on apprenne pas en reste au
niveau où on en est il vient de nommer
cette semaine henri de beauregard était
un avocat projet la manif pour tous à la
tête de la haute autorité des
républicains est ce que c'est un choix
que vous approuvez il est contesté en
interne par sa soeur et puis je ne
connaissais pas
ce beau regard est bon en tout cas il
nous a annoncé qu'il serait pas tête de
liste aux européennes
pourtant certains le pousser à y aller
ce que c'est
selon vous une bonne décision le fait de
rester en retrait de cette campagne ne
pas de pas se mouiller entre guillemets
je pense qu'il sera le chef de la
campagne
quoi qu'il en soit après laurent il est
il et il est président de la deuxième
plus grosse région française région
rhône alpes c'est un combat une mission
dans laquelle il s'investit beaucoup
il veut en faire quelque chose
d'exemplaire c'est une seule territoire
on a baissé la dépense publique ce
quelque chose qu'il faudrait qu'on a en
tête en france dont je comprends qu'il
soit attaché à l'aventuré pour incarner
ça tu as envie de faire de tourisme
maniérisme électorale c'est plutôt son à
son honneur qui pourrait incarner envers
la seule candidate qu'on connaissait
nadine morano est combien ces deux
sujets 9 que les secrets de ces d'autres
c'est la seule que je connais je
connaissais donc on connaît les députés
européens français vous avez des gens
absolument formidable 2
de dana cadec était le président de la
commission pêche par le mode ce que 1100
pêche parlement européen a condamné le
breton qui fait un travail absolument
remarquable j'avais philippe juvin qui
est grande elle sentie un peu dedans
verdure moi je sais pas qui sera leur
média sera peut-être distance à notre
sujet c'est c'est de répondre aux
aspirations de jean-pierre raffarin
pardon je dis ça en plaisantant c'est de
travailler au fond on travaille au
programme avant 2 avant de trouver
quelqu'un qui incarne ce programme une
tête de liste et ce sera le mot de la
fin
merci beaucoup les amerloques cela va
rester avec nous cette semaine merci jim
merci merci marion merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]